I think one of the most difficult things
about reforming the education system is
admitting that we have accountability if
we imagine a world that's different to
the one we live in now we all have to
take some responsibility that the future
leaders are going to come from schools
that we have now and if we better equip
students now for what the future will
look like our world will be better it's
not just about the teachers and the
students every single one of us has to
play a role every single one of us has
to take responsibility for each other at
every age especially kids were going to
school now
[Applause]
[Music]
you